[Music]
located where long before the French
settled different Aboriginal peoples
interacted with each other we wish to
pay tribute to these indigenous peoples
the descendants as well as the spirit of
brotherhood that present did over the
signing in 1700 one of the great piece
of morale her peace treaties that funded
lasting peaceful relationship between
friends it's and ingenious allies and
the OD not Shawnee the spirit of
brotherhood at the origin of this treaty
is a model for all of us
and now let's introduce our speaker
yoshua bengio it's a full professor of
the department of computer science and
operations research scientific director
of miele sefa program co-director of the
CFR learning in machines and brains
programs formerly neural contraction and
adaptive perception scientific director
of llevado
and Canada researcher in statistical
learning algorithms
his main research ambition is to
understand principles of learning that
held intelligence supervises a large
group of graduate students on postdoc
Yahshua is the computer scientist who
received the most attention burden per
day in 2018 finally he has been largely
advocating for deployment of AI for the
benefit of all not just a few Anna's and
he was instrumental in both the
organization of this workshop and other
similar initiative at Mira and elsewhere
such as the mobile declaration for the
responsible development of AI so let's
have a warm welcome for yoshua bengio
thank thank you Margo and thank you for
being here this morning very early I
think that this this kind of workshop is
really important and I'm gonna try to
articulate a bit why what's going on
here
so it's good so this workshop is is
about making sure a I is is used for the
benefit of society at large for reducing
human suffering improving social welfare
and justice and that has is agitated
through the goals of the UN sustainable
development initiative you know
education democracy urban planning
health agriculture environment and so on
and personally I feel like we in as
researchers in the eye particular we
have a responsibility to engage in a
dialogue about the use of AI because it
could be you know something really
important for the well-being of people
in the future but there are also
concerns and dangers so on the on the
hope side of course you know lots of
companies and governments are very
excited because of the economic growth
that is happening and it's just the
beginning and what is predicted is much
more which if we reduce the wealth that
will be created could mean material
progress for all it could mean you know
better ways of healing people better
ways of educating people and being able
to bring knowledge through education to
many more people
it could mean changing our relationship
to work I feel like a lot of people on
this planet are working for the wrong
reasons that they're working for having
enough money to survive and often in
conditions which are just a modern form
of slavery where they basically told
what to do and and shut their mouths
I think automation has you know
potential of creating misery by by
displacing lots of jobs but also in the
longer run to bring much more
psychologically and socially positive
environment to most people so on on the
negative side in addition to the
economic issues with with work one of
the things that I've been most involved
in is the question of the military use
of of AI and those so-called lethal
autonomous weapons I think this is this
requires all of us who are coming from
different countries to put pressure on
our governments to participate in the
current UN discussions to create a ban
for these killer robots but but in fact
the same kind of technology can be used
in a big brother' scenario and we're
seeing scary things being set up in
China where like face detection for
example could be used to track people
all over the country there's already 160
million cameras over there
tracking people 1 so these are fairly
well talked about in the media but one
area which people maybe don't talk so
much about is how a I could be used for
manipulating people in general so
whether this is through advertising such
as political advertising or social media
I mean in a social media side of course
we had Canberra general Logica which has
raised a bit of awareness about this but
I'm afraid it's just gonna go away from
consciousness for most people and
there's a deeper concern here about
democracy being in danger with these
tools able to press on our buttons for
not just making us buy Pepsi versus Coke
but you know pushing us in directions
that may not be really good for us or
for society and I guess a related issue
but maybe often something that happens
with
our being conscious of it are the issues
of biases and and discrimination that
are inherent in a lot of the datasets
that companies are using and so on that
front an important thing to know is that
there are techniques to mitigate this
and it's going to be important to put
pressure on governments to force
companies to use them and finally maybe
one of the most difficult aspect to deal
with is because AI is so powerful and
it's it's just the beginning is gonna be
even more in the future as as such you
know powerful technologies tend to make
it easier for people that have power to
acquire even more power and to lead to
increase in power concentration and
that's true at the level of individuals
you know and and like inequality in
wealth but also or between countries or
between companies and even for I think
having a well-functioning market we we
we don't want to have just one company
per sector dominating the whole sector
and it looks like we're going in that
direction so there's lots of social
issues and and many more that will be
discussed today one thing I want to
mention is the montreal declaration that
Margaux talked about briefly that i was
involved in in developing over the last
year and a half it was unveiled just the
last Tuesday and what it is is the
result of a consultation not just of
people in academia not just you know AI
researchers and scientists but people in
the humanities and social sciences but
also very importantly a long process of
getting ordinary people to give us
feedback a long process of discussion
with people in libraries here in Quebec
and a little bit in Paris to enrich the
work that had been done by by the
academics and and the result is a
document which is articulated around ten
principles so these principles touch on
different aspects by which AI and
technology may change our world in ways
that we need to have social norms about
so you know from the very general
principles of well-being from for
everyone to issues of autonomy privacy
solidarity democracy equity diversity
prudence about the technology
responsibilities of people like like me
and and sustainable development let me
just talk about one of these principles
and I'm just reading from the text of
the Declaration the development and use
of AI you must contribute to the
creation of a just and equitable society
and then for each principle there are a
number of sub principles if you want so
I'm gonna just read a few AI must be
designed and trained so as not to create
reinforce or reproduce discrimination
and development must help eliminate
relationships of domination between
groups and people based on differences
of power wealth or knowledge AI
development must produce social and
economic benefits for all by reducing
social inequalities and vulnerabilities
Industrial Development must be
compatible with acceptable working
conditions da da da anyways so I think
this is really interesting and you can
you can you can read the Declaration but
you can also sign sign up to say that
you you you you are aligned with those
principles and and and you want to
promote them in your organization so you
know go to the website just type
Montreal declaration yeah you're gonna
find it and and sign so let me go back
to the workshop very quickly because
we've started a bit late I want to
mention the
projects that we've been studying that
I've been proposed so this is the track
number two we have the papers and we
have the projects so the reviewers
identified and selected these these
projects that were selected under that
track so these these are projects that
we are proposing for the future and
where we would like the community to
pitch in so that could be donating
resources software engineers hardware
people funding researchers computation
and so on and we we want to take the
opportunity of this workshop to bring
these people together so that they can
make these projects happen
so you'll find the list of projects on
the website and just want to mention a
few about for example in fairing crop
pests dealing with forecasting floods
mapping again from using satellite
imagery to to deal with with floods and
pandemics and intelligent drone swarm
for search and rescue operations the use
of internet and and phone data for
social good tackling gender bias using
AI to enhance peer-to-peer moderation
and health forums using machine
translation to create African language
corpora algorithmic impact assessment
and and and and and connecting every
child to opportunity using information
about poverty from the UNICEF so I
encourage you to look more carefully at
these things this is a schedule for
today I think you all have it so I'm not
gonna spend time on it and just mostly
wanted to show the names and faces of
the people involved today and the
speakers so thank you very much
and organizers yes and the organizers
that I want to thank because they did a
lot of really important work so we can
move on to the first talk what oh yeah
yeah sorry sorry I forgot the sponsors
yes this would not be possible without
the sponsors so Intel Mila integrate a
iGoogle Imagi llevado Bareilles ai and
element I thanks
[Applause]